What if we get to know the probability of
us falling a prey to a particular disorder
in ADVANCE?
What if we can predict serious disorder like
cancer using simple medical testing?
Is that possible?
Or is it just fiction?
Well, no!
It’s already being done!
The concept of genetic testing or the technique
in which our genes or chromosomes are tested,
helps us here!
But what are chromosomes?
We have always come across the saying
“Humans have 23 pairs of chromosomes ”. But what
are they made up of?
And where are they actually located in the cell?
Let us try and answer all these queries in this session!
Here we have this simple cell as an example.
Can you see the thread like structures here
in the nucleus?
These threads are called Chromatids.
They are usually tangled in this fashion when
present in a regular active cell!
What if this cell has to undergo division?
Is it possible to divide this single cell
in two equal halves with such a tangled bundle
of threads?
Of course not!
Imagine we have these different coloured
threads tangled together.
If we were to separate them, then what should
be the first thing to do?
We will first separate each thread and then
make separate bunches.
In a similar way, even the cell separates
these chromatid threads.
This process is aided by Condensation of the threads.
It means these chromatid material will gradually
start coiling like a telephone wire.
As a result, the threads will gain structures like these !
Are we familiar with this kind of a structure?
Have we come across it before?
That’s correct!
It is the structure of a typical chromosome !
What are chromosomes you may ask!
Well, we will get into their details in the
upcoming sessions.
For now, we need to get a basic idea about them!
So we have this cell with threads sorted in
this classical chromosome structure.
This structure is seen only when the cell
is in the process of division.
So can we say that both chromatids and chromosomes
are the same ? Yes they are!
The different names are for the different structures!
Now the next question is, what are these threads…
or chromosomes to be precise, made up of?
If we zoom into the structure of this chromosome,
we find small segments like these that make
up the complete structure.
These functional segments are nothing but genes!
So can we say that chromosomes are made up
of genes?
Absolutely!
All these segments make up the whole structure.
Now let me ask you one more interesting question.
Do you think the genes will also be made up
of something?
Will there be units that make up these segments?
If your answer is yes, then you are absolutely
right!
Genes are also made up of some units.
If we zoom inside this gene segment, then
we find large molecules like these that make
up the segment.
These large molecules, or macromolecules to
be precise, are “DNA” molecules ! This
is not a new term for us!
We are quite familiar with the term “DNA”
as it is very commonly used these days!
But what exactly are these DNA molecules?
Well, this single large molecule is composed
of three units.
What units are these?
We will reserve this explanation for our upcoming
videos.
For now, all we need to know is that DNA is
made up of these units!
Now to quickly review what we learnt, let
me remove the text from the screen.
These three combine to give us a single molecule.
And many such DNA molecules form long chains.
What is a sequence of DNA molecules called?
That’s right!
It’s a gene!
So technically, segments of DNA molecules
which form functional units are called Genes
And many genes come together to form thread
like structures called chromosomes!
Chromosome is the classical structure obtained
only during cell division.
When the cell is not in the dividing phase,
the genetic material is present in the form
of tangled threads called Chromatids!
So this is the basic idea of the genetic material
in our cells, which we needed to understand
in order to look at the laws in genetics!
Let us get introduced to the laws in genetics
put forth by Gregor Mendel in the next part!